salut aujourd'hui mentalisme dans la rue
épisode 2 mais au lieu d'être à paris on
est à lille on a pris un train et on
s'est dit ça peut être cool de faire la
suite de cette vidéo dans une autre
ville donc je vais me promener sur la
grande place de lille et dans les rues
adjacentes dans le but de faire des
tours de mentalist par des inconnus ou à
des personnes qui me connaissent c'est
pas un souci si vous me connaissez vous
pouvez venir me voir et puis ensuite un
petit truc ensemble alors dans l'idée
j'aimerais faire trois quatre ou cinq
gros tour un peu longs ou en tout cas un
petit peu plus spéciaux et rythmé ses
torts la part des petits moments de
chifoumi on verra si on peut faire débat
tel camion à lille mentalisme dans la
rue à lille c'est parti loïc générac
on va essayer plein de choses c'est quoi
ton prénom de biot elliott connaît le
chiffon me pierre feuille ciseaux exact
vas-y en enfer s'il faut me j'ai gagné
chifoumi là j'ai gagné ici il faut me là
j'ai gagné la save the children
j'ai une carte que j'ai retourné là
dedans d'accord donc ça peut être une
carte rouge noir si elle est rouge ça
peut être coeur ou cas aussi la noire
sceptiques ou très peu et il y aurait
une valeur de cartes et c'est pas vous
qui allez décider ça c'est les personnes
que vous avez appris que vous demandez à
tous les trois d'une personne on va
commencer par toi appelle une personne
qui est susceptible de décrocher six
fautes sur un loup ça va s'étudier salut
juliette qui est rentré comme étant
arthur dans le téléphone c'est tellement
bizarre qui sort des joueurs à savoir
d'abord dire j'ai juste besoin qu'il me
choisisse une couleur en fait j'aimerais
que tu choisisses entre le rouge et le
noir c'est tout ce que tu as à faire le
rouge merci beaucoup je te rends pas son
ami merci à toi merci beaucoup c'est
parfait donc carton rouge donc ça peut
être du coeur ou du car ou est ce que tu
peux appeler quelqu'un salut je connais
pas ton prénom tu m'entends oui
écoute je t'appelle pour poser une
question très simple on fait une vidéo
dans la rue et tu dois choisir entre
coeur et caro c'est tout ce que tu as à
faire tu doit nous dire coeur ou
carrossée tout coeur ok ça me va très
bien je te repasse même quartier
beaucoup sa bio ryan tu m'entends ouais
j'ai juste besoin de que tu nous dises
une carte n'importe quelle carte cette
nuit
as 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 ghz ballet d'amour
roi c'est toi qui nous dit juste une
carte comme ça
la dame ok ça marche je ne repasserai
ismaël merci beaucoup
donc on est à la dame de coeur ok on
aurait pu dire si je demande à une
personne que la personne ne dise la dame
de coeur que si c'est une fille c'est un
peu prévu là c'est vraiment une personne
qui a choisi rouge
elle sait pas pourquoi elle a choisi
coeur c'est pas pourquoi et ryan il a
choisi dames il sait pas pourquoi non
plus je vais juste le faire du bout des
doigts tu nous tiens ça ismaël fait
voire 40 dans évidemment et je vais
aller tout lentement mais tout lentement
vous faire voir qu'à une seule carte de
retourner au milieu du jeu à l'envers et
c'est la dame de coeur et j'étais
tellement je suis sûr que la personne à
choisir et cerveau j'étais tellement si
lors que la personne
jarry culturel un but que j'étais
tellement sûr que la personne elle
choisir et rouge et dames de coeur que
c'est la seule carte rouge de tout en
appelant trois personnes d'y penser
beaucoup trop cool et chifoumi ok j'ai
perdu chifoumi ok tu as perdu chifoumi
ok j'ai perdu chifoumi qu as tu meurs
s'il vomit chifoumi ok là on est à
égalité
et maintenant on va faire le coup de la
mort si fou mais t'as pas prêt sinon ça
va c'est une bien belle ville que lille
et vous savez ce qu'on a fait juste
avant de tourner et on a mangé un welsh
c'est pas la meilleure idée à cette
chaleur entre les idéaux dans les rues
bonjour on fait une vidéo sur youtube
ont fait des tours de mentalisme dans la
rue là à paris on avait réussi pour la
première vidéo que vous avez juste au
dessus de moi on avait été obligé de
dire c'est pour faire quelque chose de
gratuit
bonjour quel est ton prénom audrey
enchanté fabien alors audrey il ya
plusieurs choses la première chose c'est
que je vais te confier un bout de papier
qui va mettre dans sa poche c'est ce
rapport tout à l'heure ne lis pas ce
qu'il ya dessus yatuu mais dans ta poche
c'est pour tout à l'heure ça c'est une
prédiction
cette enveloppe je la gardais pour moi
pour le moment et ici j'ai un plan de
l'île et des alentours de l'île comme
stéphanie 6 très bien
ça va t'aider à découvrir mon but ça va
être que tu déchire ce plan en deux puis
en de tués en deux et en plein de petits
morceaux comme ça ok tu te fais
confiance il ya rien de bizarre à faire
n'importe comment tu le déchirent et à
quoi je te demanderai de prendre des
décisions très précises est ce que vous
ne comprenez rien à ce numéro pendant
plus de trois heures c'est pas mal ce
qui est tombée est tombée on va prendre
cette règle là et je le mettrais sur mon
pied ok tu jettes quand je dis tu jettes
cette partie qu'on va détruire qu'on ne
va plus garder quand même être mon pied
tu jettes cette partie là où cette
partie de celle ci ok sur mon pied tu
continues à des chiens et plein de
petits morceaux
celle ci s'est commencé à dire ok tu
faisais de cette partie là où cette
partie là celle ci ok maintenant partir
maintenant tu vas le faire dans ton dos
tu vas prendre un des morceaux dans ton
dont celui que tu veux et tu me rends
tous les autres et toi tu gardes l'autre
morceau dans ton lit c'est bon tu vois
en rond 3 que tu ne garde pas qu'on va
jeter et toi tu gardes juste un tout
petit morceau c'est extrêmement lourd
j'adore ça ok donc l'élite reste un
petit morceau de ce style là d'accord tu
va le mettre dans leur loft rien du tout
on est d'accord tu le mets dans ton dos
directement dans l'eau c'est bon pour
toi et on cache telle enveloppe comme ça
on ne peut pas changer ce cadre dans
lequel elle est dans les mains pour le
monde toi qui étais pas de vide et ai
commencé à visiter un petit peu liquide
et donner un plan de ville tu l'a
déchiré en deux dans le sens du milieu
hôte
au départ c'est normal mais après on a
fait n'importe quoi et à chaque fois je
te demandais prendre une décision comme
ça devenait à toi en te promets temps
pour jeter c'est ce qu'on faisait
jusqu'à temps qu'ils créent c'est juste
un tout petit morceau
ok est-ce que tu as encore le papier que
des données tout à l'heure oui si tu me
mets dans ta poche c'est pour tout à
l'heure ça c'est une tradition
je vais sortir et je vais le garder ici
et je ne bougerai plus la caméra en est
témoin des fois aussi
est ce que tu peux juste ouvrir l'an
blog on va récupérer le papier qui a lui
été sécurisés tu va le prendre alors
c'est est ce qu'il ya un truc
particulier dessus de l'autre côté on a
la citadelle avec la caserne de
boufflers c'est connu ici ouais sirène
donc tout ça ça temps mené à la
citadelle
ça c'est marrant parce que de leur
laisser un papier je dis je ne changerai
pas et c'est toi qui la met dans sa
poche toulon et ce papier donné la
citadelle merci beaucoup
qu'est ce que vous voulez il faut jeter
olivier au bout d'un moment parce que
c'est tout bête et en étant aussi que
l'âge on espère tous
ça vous amuse un devoir tout faire salut
bonjour le monde se roule même été
remercié pour tes vidéos ci va devoir
traverser c'est quoi ton prénom série
continue vois tu y étais prêt pour un
chiffon mieux
vas-y 1 2 3 1 2 3 un coup pour moi 1 2 3
un coup chacun en attendant m
ce que je compte pour la vidéo et tous
peu ou pas d'enfants 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3
et voilà trois ans pour être sûr
merci à chuck métier par contre le mec
j'étais trop attaquer je l'adoré cet été
à ok j'ai complètement abandonné l'idée
d'aller voir des gens comme ya plein de
gens qui me connaissent ici j'attends
qu'ils viennent voilà après il ya la
crainte de les attendre longtemps aussi
dire que si elles sont bien les vingt
personnes qui me connaissaient à lille
et on vient de le voir c'est possible si
on sait pas après aussi il ya des gens
qui pensent que je suis mamie twink
c'est vraiment déjà arrivé et j'ai signé
ma vitrine sur un bout de papier c'est à
disneyland
ça va bien oui ok c'est quoi ton prénom
mexique maxime hockey maxime on va faire
ça ensemble mais vous allez aussi
pouvoir voir et participer en même temps
qu'elle est ce que tu connais un peu la
poésie japonaise mais pas du tout c'est
normal il est allé qu elle
jallet de prononciation qui sont parfois
hélas j'ai un petit recueil des coûts et
alors est ce que tu peux venir par
exemple le tout premier s'il te plaît et
tu ne peux pas car tu ne lis pas le
chinois mais tu as beaucoup de chance
parce que il ya les traductions derrière
genre parfum de chevelure qui nous
submerge
je suis là c'est quoi de son hémisphère
la grenouille saute dans un gros nuage
extracteur je te demander d'ouvrir sur
l'un d'entre eux de le lire qu'est ce
matin tous dans ta tête
évidemment vous pouvez le regarder aussi
en même temps mais faut pas que je
puisse l'entendre le voir hockey soit tu
crois que tu vas pas te rappeler par
coeur et qui ont fermé tu gardes ton
doigt quand même quelque part ça marche
ok c'est moi qui m'occupe sais pas vous
comme ça vous jouez les filmer et toi tu
ouvres à un étui
là c'est bon mon but du jeu c'est de
retrouver évidemment le poème mais je
suis mentaliste je suis pas devin je
peux pas deviner comme ça en claquant
des doigts par contre j'utilise ça parce
que c'est très imagé en général tu vois
genre le premier c'était la grenouille
au menu phare tu vois il ya vraiment des
images par rapport à ça donc je vais
vous demander d'imaginer une
représentation graphique très simple
dans votre tête c'est bon tu peux avoir
une image tu peux t'en faire une image
ou pas c'est plus dur pour toi
non c'est bon et toi ok on t'oublie on
oublie complètement ok vous regardez du
côté de ma main et vous imaginez votre
dessin comme s'ils étaient sur une
feuille comme ça tu vois et moi je vais
faire des trucs un peu bizarres sur le
au milieu en bas pour voir et vous
ramener beaucoup vers le haut donc moi
je vais faire des choses ici vers le
haut comme ça pourrait faire des trucs
un peu comme ça je vais attaquer un peu
le bas de l'image pour voir ce qui
pourrait y avoir plusieurs éléments
d'accord c'est 3,4
ok ok c'est bon c'est pas du tout ce que
ça peut vouloir dire tu vois ce que j'ai
dessiné ou pas nous y voilà et bien
maintenant on va vous demander votre
poème et on espère juste que ça un
niveau c'est pas sûr de moi dit si je
vous promets que c'est pas ça je
diffuserai quand même est-ce que tu peux
me dire le poème que tu avais ans est
telle et femmes pour la ronde vers des
contrées
avec l'histoire des femmes font la ronde
avec les étoiles écoute on est pas mal
bravo j'étais tellement passeur de moi
maxime je te laisse anthony a rien
d'utile amour et bien nous sommes
repartis on nous sommes dans une autre
direction
mais je ne sais pas où le riz qui est ce
que tu veux qu'on aille vers la gare et
là bas qu'est ce qu'en pense oui aller
allons-y
nous on aime bien faire du mentalisme
dans la rue alors vous savez quoi on a
fait paris on a fait lille vous le dites
dans l'espace commentaire quelle ville
vous aimeriez que je fasse et on va
essayer d'en faire quelques uns chaque
année et au bout de 20 ans j'aurais fait
toutes les villes de france peut-être ou
pas mais non mais dites moi ça peut être
non qui ont la rochelle j'adorerais
bordeaux angers montpellier j'en sais
rien c'est vous qui le dites
et puis on se donne des points de
rendez-vous comme ça et moi je marche et
faut tomber sur moi et je vous fais du
mentalisme des stands pense me
contentant pas cette fois un chiffon me
bien d'autres aussi commis
auquel chifoumi
s'il faut me un bond à chifoumi devant
un chiffon me pas pour moi
[Musique]
ce qui me navre
si tu attends téléphone portable il est
sur toi il est allumé il est bloqué par
un code à quatre chiffres le quai par un
code de coaching dans mon but est de
retrouver ses codes parce que ce ne
serait pas seulement tu va regarder
d'avoir mon doigt et tu vas penser aux
attentes tout premiers chiffres du code
ok t'as pas être 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 0 1
2 3 4 5
non je sois efficace et ça ok ça marche
je vais noter déjà le premier que comme
moi j'avais en tête le fait voir à loïc
est ce que tu peux dire juste dire le
premier film de ton code de déblocage
ok 2 2 ouais pas mal je cherchais le
suivant on garde toujours dans les yeux
ça peut être un deux trois quatre cinq
six sept huit neuf dix vous avez vu
quand est-ce qu'il a réuni ses mains
juste après celui dont j'ai besoin je
pense si si je m'étais tous les chiffres
de 0 à 9 euros étant là et 9 étant là
est ce que tu peux regarder le plus
rapidement possible le ton troisième
chiffre faisait aussi
ok super c'est à dire qu'il manque qu'un
est ce que tu peux me dire en pensant à
ton dernier chiffre 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 lundi 1 287 studio du hockey il n'y a
pas mille 0 c'est l'accepter 0 c'est
cool est-ce que je prends le téléphone
ou c'est bon j'espère tu as ton piquant
j'espère que tu as ensuite les gens ils
veulent que je me trompe quoi alors
attends comment je fais pour
déverrouiller le slide vers le haut
ok ok comme ça j'aurais dit non
sinon comment il va quand un fernandez
code merci à lui
ainsi s'achève ce tournage à lille pour
mentalist dans la rue deux comme je vous
le dis vous regardez dans l'espace
commentaire vous nous mettez dans quelle
ville voulait qu'on vienne faire ça et
puis bah ma foi on n'ira pas à liker la
vidéo si elle vous a plu merci à tous
ceux et celles qui ont participé ici
vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne ici
la chaîne secondaire ici le dernier
mentalisme dans la rue enfin c'est à
dire le premier ici une autre vidéo
c'est cool à très bientôt
ciao